In June of 2014,
a single barrel of oil cost $114.
Today the price is just $50.
This drop is far beyond the usual
fluctuations of price of this raw
material and it's beyond the predictions
of pessimistic defenders of the peak oil
theory,
the theory that we are about to have a
severe shortage because petroleum is
always running out more when the truth
is that there are many different factors
that suggest that the price of petroleum
is going to remain low for quite some
time.
This is mainly due to two reasons.
The first is the constant improvements
of energy efficiency,
meaning that we have a lesser need for
energy.
This is logical when you think that the
group of OACD countries,
that's the world's wealthiest countries
are using the same amounts of primary
energy as they used in the year 2000,
but they are producing 30 percent more.
For us is the biggest market with 40,000
plugin cars purchased there in the first
six months of this year.
The second reason is innovation and
technological development,
a field of expertise that is inherent to
human evolution.
This is a development that has occurred
on two fronts,
both fossil fuels as well as renewable
energies.
The best example of this might be
fracking.
This is a technology that has provided
the wells with a large amount of oil as
well as natural gas.
In fact,
this technology alone has led to the u s
doubling its oil production and it's
currently that country is producing more
oil than it has since the 19 seventies.
Now,
on the other hand,
the ecological impacts of fracking is a
highly controversial topic that that's
something we're going to address in a
later video.
Now,
the reduced price of oil has been an
incredible sense back for Persian Gulf
countries where 85 percent of their
revenue relies on this until now.
This has allowed for the payments of all
kinds of bills.
Citizens of got use to high levels of
subsidies and allowances while also
getting used to not having to pay any
taxes to subsidize everything.
Water,
electricity,
fuel,
low interest loans,
and citizens have also got used to the
idea that they have a right to a well
paid civil service
job.
More countries in the Persian Gulf of
gotten used to spending an enormous
amounts of money on guns.
In fact,
they've spent so much money on weaponry
that Saudi Arabia now spends more on its
military than Russia.
This makes it the country with the third
largest military budget globally.
We all
know that oil money has paid for pro
Islamic campaigns all around the world.
However,
these preexisting policies have become
completely unsustainable due to the drop
in the price of oil.
In fact,
in 2015 alone oil producing countries
last $360,000,000,000
in oil revenues.
Yeah,
and this is all because of the harder
drop in the price of oil.
Now I'm going get me wrong.
They do still get an enormous amounts of
money from oil.
Saudi Arabia,
for example,
against around $5,500
per capita from it's black gold mounted
display link,
this still significant amounts of
income.
They are able to maintain all of the
subsidies that they have established
because of this changing scenario,
all countries in the Persian Gulf are
announcing ambitious plans to diversify
their economies.
This will allow them to get some
distance from the economy's completely
relying on oil they aren't looking to
follow do by his example,
which has been one of the only countries
do successfully transitioned away from a
totally oil based economy in the last 40
years.
Because of this
diversification away from the emirates
is becoming a world leader in terms of
poor ism trade and the stick.
Tens of billions of dollars are being
invested into Qatar with the hope that
it will become an economy of knowledge.
They proudly show off their education
city development,
a huge educational complex where some of
the most prestigious schools in the
wells can be found.
There are also notable researchers
working there with budgets that seem
almost infinite.
However,
the most archetypical case is the one we
find in Saudi Arabia,
one of the world's most suffocating and
terrifying countries.
Human Rights in Saudi Arabia are nothing
more than an illusion.
Women are forced to marry under rage and
they can't even drive further.
Dozens of executions occur every year,
and torture is quite routine lasts for
me.
Homosexual acts,
trees,
treason and murder,
a punishable by death through beheading
and Saudi Arabia and the Islamic state.
Further,
the country has even banned theaters and
nightclubs in Saudi Arabia.
Religion and fundamentalism are more
important than anything else.
Last economic crisis cannot be escaped
and today they are facing a very complex
situation.
In 2015,
the deficit was at 15 percent of the GDP
and this continued into 2016.
This is threatening to swallow up all of
the money that they saved during the
black gold of years.
Further,
unemployment is becoming a major concern
and this is no more true than among
young people.
The unemployment rate is currently
sitting for young people at around 40
percent.
This is why in April 2016,
Prince Mohammed,
Bill Sahlman,
the strongest man in the kingdom,
announced an ambitious reform plan known
as Saudi Vision Twenty,
30.
The goal of this reform plan is nothing
less than do transform the country's
economy.
They say,
look,
this is a good plan.
We need to diversify our way because of
necessity.
Otherwise the country will have far more
difficulties in the years to come.
The plan aims to achieve total
independence from oil by 20 slash 20 and
become one of the most globally
competitive economy is by 20,
30.
The first step of this stance by
privatizing Aramco.
This is one of the world's largest
companies which controls 10 percent of
global oil production.
The company's estimated value is five
times that of apple with all the money
from them.
Privatization,
addition of foreign reserves of the
privatization of public companies,
and it's real estate.
Saudi Arabia wants to generate a
sovereign wealth funds,
have $2,000,000,000,000
tell them to get a more predictable and
stable income than they are currently
getting from oil.
They will see once you eliminate many of
the subsidies that are currently
threatening their economy and to invest
in new sectors like mining,
finance,
and importantly the military industry.
Uber is getting a three and a half a
billion dollar investment from Saudi
Arabia's public investment fund.
New taxes are also going to be
introduced as another method of earning
for the governance.
The prince still wants to change the
higher educational system,
which is currently closer to the Koran
and develop.
It's to meet modern market requirements,
but the big question has to be,
is Saudi Arabia going to succeed?
It is no easy task for a country to
quickly become an industrial power and
it is unlikely that tourists are going
to be drawn to a country which sees
people regularly,
stones for homosexuality or adultery.
However,
all of that said,
Saudi Arabia success will benefit the
wells no matter how repulsive we
personally find that policies.
Seventy percent of the Saudi population
is under 30 years old and over the next
10 years they're going to require 2
million jobs.
We all know that when frustration
unemployment's ends,
religious fundamentalism add up.
The consequences can be truly dangerous
to the Bonnie has proved that moderation
and capitalism can lead to changes in
fundamentalist regimes.
We can only hope that Saudi Arabia can
successfully follow the example that has
been set by Dubai,
but that is our opinion here at visual
politic.
We want to know what you think.
Do you think Saudi Arabia will succeed?
Do you think it will successfully follow
the example that has been set by Dubai?
Do you think that capitalism can
encourage moderation in countries like
Saudi Arabia?
Do you let us know your opinion in the
comments below?
We're looking forward to reading them
and if he did like this video,
why don't you give it a thumbs up below?
It really helps us out and don't forget
to subscribe,
but our brand new videos just like this
every Monday and every Thursday,
so if you subscribe you won't miss any
of those and they'll see you next time.